[Music]
identity politics and this politically
correct regulations to a large extent
for me they are a perfect example of
this how to make big bombastic
rhetorical changes
without really changing anything
when we talk about identity politics and
its determinism
slavos said on page 107 of his book
against double blackmail refugees come
from a culture that is incompatible with
western european notions of human rights
that is identity politics
slovenia is a population of 2.1 million
people there were 3
548 applications for asylum in slovenia
last year
550
of those applications were unaccompanied
children
there's a rejection rate of 70
and only 87 people got refugee status
now a question to ask here
when considering perry anderson who
understood
hegemony well it's merely in the night
of our ignorance that all alien shapes
take on the same hue when we look at the
eu as having 35 000 people across the
last few decades die trying to enter
to talk about the
incompatibility of them culturally is to
dance on the watery graves of those who
died well let me put that too
let me put that to him because i mean
that's quite a big thing to say and and
it's directly about the question of
identity politics and freedom so slava
do you do you want to respond to that
first please don't make me in any sense
a representative of slavin politics i'm
here totally excluded we have now in
slovenia a radical right-wing
nationalist anti-immigrant government
which is
even slowly outcasted by european union
i refer to them as part of the new axis
of evil slovenia hungary poland
the second
thing nonetheless and here probably we
will disagree
i don't i don't i think this is already
too much of a liberal trick
to make
the problem of to make openness to the
refugees
the main test of how open we are and so
on and so on
i think that that
the true problem is what is happening
there in those countries from where
refugees come and in what sense yes
we western europeans are to a large
extent response
responsible for it
the first step is to see the real
problems
and
and
i am sorry here okay i may be excuse of
being a right winger that's why i'm in
trouble now but i don't agree absolutely
not that there are immigrants who want
to become part of the western society
and we are just unwilling to
integrate them the situation is far more
far more
complex
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas